[Music]
[Applause]
he's Kevin James actor comedian he's got
a comedy special irregardless premieres
today on Amazon his Al don't walk tour
begins February 3rd tickets available at
Kevin james.com so you're uh joining us
from Kelly Clarkson studio and then
you're gonna go on her show yes I'm uh
whatever backstage now I'm in a one of
the dressing rooms here you ever been in
a bad Green
Room I've been in a very few good
ones yeah I uh most of the ones a lot of
the ones on the you know these these
beautiful theaters you play you know
when you're doing standup uh they're
they're over a 100 years old and the uh
I think the green rooms are 150 years
old they had tiny little you
know they're they're tough they're
pretty tough but um this one's actually
pretty nice it's not too bad now do you
have things in your Rider when you do
your standup special you go City to City
any any demands there that might
surprises yeah it's it's not crazy like
you'd think um it's just uh I just think
coffee or something like that literally
nothing I don't I'm pretty easy we bring
stuff you know my diet changes every
three minutes so you
know I'm into agave and now I'm not now
honey you can't have honey and now so
it's like we just bring our own whatever
it is I'm trying to do whatever whatever
wave I'm trying to catch to get in shape
next I was wondering when you did cameos
on Everybody Loves Raymond right now did
that lead to King of Queens be no no it
help not connected not connected in that
way no I had a uh a development deal at
NBC and um we were developing the show
uh but what really helped me solidify it
I was at NBC then when we we were
starting the process they didn't they
they passed on the show The King of
Queens but because Ry uh invited me to
write an episode with him we wrote one
on on golf uh that was the one that I
was able to write and get in on and and
CBS saw it and said that they would they
were okay giving me my own show so it it
helped H you know he was such a big help
in in all that when you do stand up and
you go out and test this material
I'm I'm assuming you go out to smaller
clubs and test but if it doesn't go well
is the joke removed or
Rewritten it depends I mean it depends
on you know I I will you know sometimes
I'll force things and I'll be like NOP
this is funny that audience was not
great and I'm gonna try it again and uh
sometimes they prove me wrong where I'm
like o I've tried so many times it's
just a pain in the ass to get this thing
going and it's just not working so um
you know I'm pretty good at knowing I
think this is going to work for me uh
but I've written bits like way too long
you know and done the whole thing and it
ends up you know I lose the audience
with it so it's like it ends up just
being a really short bit but it's still
in there you know it's a funny punch and
then you're out tougher to start a
comedy show or end a comedy
show that's a good question um I think
start
I think start
because when when you come on stage they
give you a couple minutes you know
they're just excited to see you which is
nice so they're really really happy with
you but if you don't hit them with the
first few jokes or you miss or
something's a little off and your timing
is a little off you can lose them it's
more dangerous there by the end of the
show you've kind of built up a you know
a relationship with them and and they
kind of know you know they hopefully
like you at that point so it's a little
easier I think to end although I've
missed endings like I've G you know gone
to my big closer and it didn't go so
I've got to go on and try to find
another one you know it's like you try
to go get out on that last big laugh and
if it doesn't go you got to find another
also you like go into Extra Innings with
this yes it's Extra Innings it's it's
it's not fun and and I and I'll torture
them because I'll just stay as
long as long as necessary yeah hey I'm
not leaving until you guys start
laughing so yeah yeah uh when you were
younger did you ever follow somebody who
crushed like do you remember that
feeling and who it was oh yeah I mean I
remember seeing Sandler uh I first met
him at the comic strip uh in New York
and I just went up to him and and he was
really nice to me and I watched him just
brush uh and uh Ry was one of the first
ones that I saw Crush too uh you know it
was uh I was hosting it you remember the
young comedian special the HB young
comedian special they were doing uh you
know auditions for that and I got to
host it so I was on all night long mcing
and I watched these guys come up and I
was trying to be seen myself to see if I
got on if I can get on and all these
comedians would come on and they would
just Hammer Hammer Hammer and then Ray
came on and I'm like how is he gonna
follow this last guy whoever it was just
destroyed and Ray's just very low key so
um but he did he changed he he he he
taught me a lesson that like he settled
into the audience like he just he just
did his he stayed at his Pace where I
would have tried to amp it up and try to
get him going you know and just be
louder um he stayed at his pace and the
first joke didn't go as well but then he
got him and he crushed and he and he
ended up getting that special I
didn't nor nor McDonald had a unique
delivery crazy great yeah how would you
describe that style I mean it's not
traditional no no it was uh it was so
unique and that was just so you know he
was so committed to it and there was
nowh else to go you know that's the
thing it wasn't like he went into a
character and and delivered a joke that
way that was him and I I loved it so
much that you know he's again so
different than anything you've seen uh
or will see probably you know it just it
was that
ah just that that style he didn't care
that if you cared it is like hey I care
and if you don't that's okay like you
know you know move on with this uh we're
talking to Kevin James he has his comedy
special premieres today on Amazon it's
called irregardless and uh his owls
don't want tour begins February 3rd
tickets available at Kevin james.com
familyfriendly standup on Amazon yes how
important was it to do it that
way it you know it was important for me
U 30 years ago that's what happened you
know it's like I used to curse like a
crazy man with all my buddies and you
know but I realized that it was more out
of laziness like I didn't want to change
my set if I ever got The Tonight Show or
if I got a TV spot I just started saying
I I gotta Write Clean I don't want to
have to change my material that's why I
don't do any like political stuff or
current events like I didn't want to
write stuff that I'm I'm gonna lose it
after it's done so it's like to build a
universal act for me was like it was
important and and it just kind of
settled in that way you know and I just
you know I I try to write that way I
don't think about it like oh I gotta
right clean now but uh it just happens
that way and you know it can be
challenging sometimes but it it it works
out recap your year as a New York Jet
fan oh my gosh it's just getting more
and more depressing because I'm saying
the same thing every year you know it's
it's it's you know and I didn't lead
with this Kevin you know I waited till
the very end I know by the way I was
there opening night you know for uh
Rogers yes and uh I didn't make it into
the stadium before he got I was in the
parking lot walking in and it was over
you just heard this massive you know the
energy just left the stadium and I was
like you knew something was wrong and
you're like who what was that and of
course we you know we find out I was it
four plays in or something and it just I
mean it felt like it would felt across
the the whole NFL I mean everybody you
know just it was an exciting thing to go
for you to to root for and to to see how
it's going to turn out whether you're a
Jet fan or not and when that was taken
away it just I don't know would you have
given up one of your Healthy Achilles to
keep Rogers in their quarterback oh yeah
like was that like a kidney thing yeah
yes yes yes what am I doing you know
you're not using your Achilles no I
haven't used it in years in years okay
you can have both by the way we have an
undercover skid idea Paulie okay so you
know King of Queens we all know the role
you played on King of Queens what if you
went as a mean-spirited UPS driver
undercover where it's clearly it's you
but you're not the nice guy from CBS
you're not the nice UPS driver and see
if people figure it out and their
reaction as they confuse you as the
celebrity to just a UPS driver okay
hilarity would ensue that's the elevator
pitch there from Paulie might produc
yeah by the way I couldn't be more
confused myself right now that's part of
it you play an undercover UPS driver
basically I'm an undercover okay but
people may recognize you as your role
from King of Queens right but I'm not
that guy no more mean-spirited because
you're kind of look tough right now with
the bald and the and the right goatee
with the yeah a little bit more edgy
right I gotta smile more yeah is that
what your wife says yeah all the time
smile she's like what are you doing yeah
it is a little little bit uh I don't I
don't realize that the without the hair
youd look a little like you're angry
there's a wrestler feel to you yeah a
big show kind of like yes and and you
played a wrestler
before well yeah a fight MMA fighter oh
I didn't play okay but yes wrestle you
wrestled in high school I wrestled one
year in high school I wrestled against
uh Mick Foley you know uh Mick Foley was
on uh went to my high school and my
college by the way but he uh I was a
running back in high school uh and the
our team needed a heavyweight uh so they
brought me in I'd never wrestled before
I was a strong kid uh so I I had like a
double Leg Takedown that's all I had so
if I could take you down and squeeze you
you know I would I would win a lot of
matches uh but if if if you knew
anything about wrestling you could you
could beat me easily and uh I remember
one match it came down to that because I
think Mick was hurt or I don't know what
it was they needed me and it was a big
match that was going back and forth and
when you're a heavyweight you wrestle
last so uh it was an away game or away
match and uh I was going against this
big kid and I remember I was so panic
because everybody like turned to me and
it was one of those like in a sports
movie where it just everybody looked at
me and and it was like you're in and it
was like Vision Quest you know I take
the head you know you put the headset on
you get in there I put my foot on the
line and they're like go and I I double
egged him and he I went back on him and
then he rolled me immediately and he was
so big I couldn't breathe I was
suffocating under him and I was fighting
like crazy and he ended up pinning me
and we lost and it was the worst I just
remember the bus ride home two things I
remember everybody being quiet and and
probably hating me and I remember number
two I smelt just like that
guy so I had to smell and a quiet ride
home you didn't mind being called a
heavyweight I I always wondered about
that hey you're the
heavyweight no I was in good shape like
I liked it because most heavyweights
were back then I I wasn't ripped but I
was in I was in good shape I wasn't I
was like 200 pounds maybe or 195
whatever but I was like you know You' go
against these guys that were just you
know grass-fed big big guys but luckily
you've gotten over that embarrassing
moment that you had just
now yeah uh have fun with Kelly Clarkson
and good luck with the special
irregardless premieres today on Amazon
familyfriendly and owl's don't walk walk
tour begins February 3rd tickets
available Kevin james.com thank you Kev
hi buddy thank you good to see you Kevin
James I think we've been in like five
movies together like Redford and Newman
you two well not exactly that we were in
a now pronounced shoot Chuck and lar I
was in grown-ups 1 and two I was in huie
Halloween and I think there's one other
one that we were in
together and we were in a few scenes
together but uh is there another one
that you see Paulie on his uh IMDb that
I might have been in since I've been in
I think 20 of Sandler movies I mean
technically we've all been in a scene
with K uh pixel pixel sweet he was up at
the podium yes yes yes yes yes we were
uh we were in that movie as well up in
Toronto